what do you think the kind of apparatus
of the four-year degree in college is
going to look like in 20 years
oh that's I mean we're like day by day
that seems to be changing with GPT I
don't know if you've gotten a chance to
interact with tragic absolutely
my entire show now is written by Chachi
I mean there's uh that's partially a
joke uh it is only because it stopped
looking at the internet at 20 in 2021.
if it was current I could completely
just tune it out no I'm kidding but it's
a fascinating tool and uh it's changing
the nature of how we uh do homework
assignments it's changing the nature of
how we learn how we look up new
information how we explore information
how we care about things we're
interested in I think it
um I I don't think we'll have
value for University degree in 20 years
the way we do now I just think it
changes everything I think
language models I mean Google search has
already in Wikipedia has already
transformed I would say our civilization
but it's there was still a value for
basic education I don't I think that
starts to dissipate uh with with child
gbt so I don't I don't know yeah um I I
really I really don't think there's a
university the way we think of a
university in 20 20 30 years the I mean
I have a personal interest in it in that
my daughter is 10 months old yeah and
I'm doing the 529 account I'm going
through the motions as if
but I also recognize you know if she
went to the schools I went to just with
the rate of tuition increase you're
talking 200k a year by the time she's
18. and what happens with wages relative
to that this is like separate from the
technological thing
um and in my mind I'm thinking is this
going to continue being the right path
what I would love to see is so many
people that I interact with just by
virtue of what I do
have no foundation in critical thinking
epistemology philosophy or media
literacy and
if there were some way to make that the
core of some basic education that
everybody's receiving
which goes beyond you know chat GPT can
do so many things but I've not yet seen
good examples of how it can teach you to
think maybe you have a different view on
how chat gbt can teach a user to think
but those skills seem to be so lacking
and so many of the people I interact
with if there's any positive change to
come from a changing Dynamic with higher
education I wish it would be to go in
that direction well no
um chat GPT is actually much better
helping me think than any educator even
books that I've encountered because it
it's very good at presenting the full
picture even better than a lot of
Wikipedia articles you know on questions
like did the virus leak from a lab
it just presents to you all the
different hypotheses the amount of
evidence available to it it's like it's
like a full calm objective picture of it
there's no partisanship it's like a
really nice list of things that's
available but I guess what I mean is
does it tell you how as a thinking human
you should evaluate the strength of each
of the paragraphs it presents to you you
can literally ask you can ask it to do a
fair okay yeah and then it's actually a
fun
it's fun to ask Chad GPT that question
because you'll get good answers and so
you basically uh have a kind of Socratic
like a a deep intimate like great
podcast style conversation with an AI
system
every single day for as many hours as
you want as it especially as it improves
as and as the interfaces by which you
communicate with the thing improves so
yeah I think I think it will do exactly
that which is teach you how to think
because you will offload the memory of
facts and
um equations and whatever else uh School
teaches you you'll offload that to Ai
and instead you'll be using your human
mind which is uh what it for now is
uniquely good at which is asking good
questions thinking uh through the
complexities of issues when there's
multiple perspectives on it all of that
well then I stand corrected maybe then I
don't know what college is going to be
in 20 years well but you were sort of
commenting it I see to the the financial
aspect of it like why does it even make
sense yeah
I'm thinking about the transformative
effects of AI and what it starts to ask
what is the
what is even education right what do you
suppose what is the purpose of education
so one is to give you a kind of a
background knowledge of on a bunch of
different topics but the other is to
discover the thing you're truly
passionate about and the thing you're
really good at such that you can make
money and you can contribute to society
and have a fulfilling life yeah and also
learning to interact with other people
without relationships are built
socializing and so many other things as
well but is that you know that is the
big value of University yeah and maybe
you should be called something else can
you get that for less than 200k a year
exactly or else yeah no it's a fair
question a kind of social club and you
know one of the things I think about
also is people who are well connected I
mean this has always been this isn't new
right but if you're well connected and
you have a sort of drive towards
entrepreneurship and doing your own
thing and you're not pursuing a field
that is very licensing dependent like
medicine or law
um getting started four years earlier
with some internships can be a privilege
in some cases but again that's that path
is available to the people that would
likely do well regardless of whether
they went to college and so it's a very
privileged self-selected group anyway